[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
hello i'm professor brian keating the
co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at the university of
california san diego
and i'm also the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics as
well
today we're going to be talking about
the limits of imagination
with inspiration from our namesake the
person who gave us the name of this
podcast
into the impossible arthur c clarke who
said the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them
into the impossible and of course
imagination
goes hand in hand with science and
curiosity and my motto of course is
always be
curious abc because that will stoke
the imaginative fires that we need to
proceed and make progress in physics and
no one was more of a big supporter of
that than albert einstein who said
famously imagination
is more important than knowledge i know
sometimes i like to have my you know
surgeon have good knowledge too
i don't want them to be too imaginative
when they're doing stuff down there but
uh nevertheless i hope today you're
going to be inspired by
a little discussion that i've been
working on along with my late great
colleague andrew friedman
and that's called how big is the world
how big is the universe
and are there other universes this is a
question
as old as time so from ancient days
people used to draw
pictures of the universe as they knew it
the world and ask questions how big
is it and there they would say there can
sometimes be
dragons here and we can look back in
this early illustration over here
that's the family on uh woodcut that
shows a figure
peering out into the distance and seeing
what lies beyond what you can see
the limits of your own mind and you can
see things in your mind that you can't
see with your eyes
as this individual is depicted doing now
what i'm curious about is what are the
improvements
that we've made in our understanding of
the universe so the first kind of
revolution i talked about in my book
losing the nobel prize
and the so-called five great debates
centered upon
whether or not our position in the
universe is somehow privileged or not
and copernicus and galileo and others
help to answer this question that the
earth
is not the center of the universe but
today
in the question of the multiverse one
can ask legitimately
is ours the only universe or are we a
population
set contained within the multiverse and
are we the center of the multiverse
where do these notions of the multiverse
come from so we don't believe we're the
center of the universe
and yet we know that there are horizons
and so
it turns out there's a limit to what we
can see here in san diego
we can go out to the ocean we can look
upon it we can see boats coming from
over the horizon
so we know there are things out there we
can even learn about distant processes
earthquakes tsunamis and things that
travel from far distant locations before
they reach us
we get their signals not in the form of
light that we could see but in the form
of
other forms of information now it turns
out
many many scientists have looked into
this question how many different types
of multiverse are there
and it turns out there's more than just
one there's more than two
and perhaps there may be as many as four
so the question of how many different
types of multiverses there are is a rich
question
and it dovetails in with the copernican
principle rather nicely
because the question is how can we test
for the existence
of multi-verses and what evidence do we
have for other types of properties
that we can access using just our
current set of observations
so we have evidence for other planets
other stars things beyond the horizon
and so forth those have been replete for
many years
so the next question is are there other
universes this is what i call the next
or fifth great debate
we know we can access other places by
land and this has been known since the
cave dwellers
uh thousands of years ago depicting
people walking and you can go out and
access other places by land quite easily
you can also take a boat and go other
places by sea people have known about
this for so long
so these are ways that we access other
regions that you can't see from a
current location
by physically transporting yourself
you can also observe things that you
can't physically transport yourself to
other planets here are depictions over
the centuries of planets like
that of uh depicted by galileo who's
shown with a telescope much bigger than
the actual one he used
but nevertheless it gives you an idea
peering out in the early 1600s
and seeing things like the moons of
jupiter and the lobes or ears as he
called them
of saturn so these are all things we can
encounter without going to them so you
can see them
we can see other stars we've never been
to another star we can see other
galaxies even with your eye you can see
the most distant thing you can see with
your eyes the andromeda galaxy
about 3 million light years away that
means the light left that galaxy
when there were still hominids in africa
roaming around the serengeti plane
millions of years ago predating homo
sapiens
you see the hubble deep field the hollow
ultra deep field and we see that almost
every image every speck of light in this
image is a galaxy not a star
in our milky way galaxy but another
galaxy itself
a galaxy cluster many galaxy clusters in
the hubble deep field and beyond
and if you just simply make a
calculation an estimate from
this image or the hubble deep field
image you can estimate how many galaxies
are there approximately in the visible
universe and it turns out to be about a
hundred billion
galaxies that we could observe just in
our observable universe since the
creation of our
observable universe uh 13.8 billion
years ago
so it's natural to want to think about
well there could be other universes
here's a picture of the cosmic microwave
background as we see it depicted as sort
of a deity looking out in our universe
i also happen to have a model of our
universe in this form it's a beach ball
this one differs from that one because
it has the galaxy which is replete with
in
emission from dust from electrons
zipping around
and the actual universe that we observe
with microwave vision
is uh is quite indicative of a process
that that took place very long ago that
casts the dying
terms of the patterns that we now see so
some of the earliest multiverse ideas
are
really tied to the ancient idea of kind
of the copernican principle which is one
of humility
that we are not the center of the solar
system the galaxy uh
the universe and perhaps maybe there's
even more to our universe
these sometimes go by the name of bubble
universes or isolated universes and
theories that we'll discuss on this
channel as well
well we can look back in cosmic history
as depicted here a modified uh plot
courtesy of nasa
and it shows the universe starting from
a period of early
inflation which is our best candidate
model for how the universe may have
emerged
from some initial condition it is not a
theory itself of the initial conditions
but it's a theory of perhaps best
thought of as a way to get structure
forming
models to work in the early universe by
by no means is it the only theory there
are other theories that we'll explore on
this channel
including bouncing and cyclic
cosmological moms
the universe evolves it creates hydrogen
hydrogen at 380 thousand years after the
big bang produced
the cmb at that same epoch we then
observed the cmb
and we're hoping to use patterns in the
cmb to infer what the universe might
have been like
at times predecessing to when we observe
the cosmic background radiation
so we have evidence we have evidence for
these cosmic processes
we have evidence for matter we have
evidence for a very very brief but
energetic phase of the universe called
big bang nucleosynthesis
when the elements like hydrogen helium
and their and their isotopes
form the lightest elements in the
periodic table and we also have evidence
in the form of
matter and light that we see from the
cosmic microwave background
and from even our local earth
environment we can actually get a handle
on
what the early universe's properties
must have been like and it was an early
fusion reactor
which only can take place at extremely
high temperatures and extremely high
densities
now how did it get into that state is
the subject of inflation and other
models
that we'll discuss in other videos so
the question of how far you can see is a
question of horizon
one of horizon just like on the ocean if
you're at sea level you can only see a
certain distance
until your eye is not possible to
glimpse things beyond it because the
earth curves away
and so what is the farthest distance we
can see in the universe back to the
so-called big bang event when the
universe synthesized the lightest
elements in the periodic table
and it's important not to conflate the
origin of the universe with the big bang
it may be that the big bang was the
origin of time but it may not be
and there are other models that we'll
talk about including videos with julian
barber
and others that have different theories
of time different theories of
singularity free origins of the universe
i hope to get into all of that in future
episodes
we can actually do calculations this is
a calculation for my course in cosmology
with professor barbara ryden's wonderful
book and she is a guest on the
into the impossible podcast we'll have a
link to that video as well
and this is in her chapter 5 just to
show you what some of these equations
look like
but actually we can calculate them quite
accurately thanks to the observational
input data
that define the matter and energy
content of our universe as we observe it
today
then using the known laws of physics and
assuming the constants of nature do not
change over the course of the universe
we could propagate those back in time
and we can ask what was the universe
like at
previous eras in our history and what
will the universe be like in the future
we can make hypotheses as to what will
happen
and in so doing we come upon an
inescapable fact at least in the context
of inflation
that there may be what's called a
multiverse but the first kind of
notion of the multiverse is that there
could be a universe outside
our universe within our universe namely
we can only see back to the creation of
the big bang the elements that produce
signals that we can see
and that occurred 13.8 billion years ago
but because the universe has expanded
since then
the actual radius or if you like the
diameter of the observable universe is
more like 92
billion light years more than three
times in radius what you'd expect
naively from just multiplying the speed
of light times the age of the universe
and there could be actually stuff
outside of that people ask me what's
beyond that
well i like to say if you go out outside
the space station
with a little box and you fill up that
box it'll have some stuff in it it'll
have photons in it
from the sun some photons from the big
bang in the form of the cmb maybe a
proton or two some dark matter
sprinkled in some dark energy we don't
know much about that
but it will have all these things inside
of it and then between those things will
be nothing
so it could be that's what we're
expanding into there could be some
vast enormous space every point possible
an
infinite number of points that are
possible in space and time extending in
all directions north south east west
backwards and forwards
in all directions and we can only see
back to where a creation event occurred
such with a long enough time in the past
that we are just now receiving
information
from what's called the surface of last
scattering this teal colored circle
depicted here
so but that's not everything or it may
not be everything it could be everything
there may be nothing outside of the
entire universe or the cosmos or the
megaverse or whatever you want to call
it without there having to be
multiple universes like ours could be
that there are other things out there
could be there's nothing out there
nothing being exactly what's outside the
space station
so there could be other universes that
would have their own kind of cmb beach
balls
that could have the same laws of nature
that we have the same physical
newton's laws einstein's laws
schrodinger's laws etc etc
uh and it could have the same constants
of nature same gravitational force
constant
the same speed of light but it would
have different initial conditions
and therefore the exact pattern that we
see would look slightly different
the same way that breeding a chicken or
something like that you can start with
roughly the same ingredients but you can
get a different organism from that
now we don't know where the initial dna
comes from where the structure comes
from it doesn't come from evolution
itself
there's an origin of life problem we'll
talk about that as well as well as many
other fascinating aspects of life on
this channel
in subsequent videos so we know that
there are a possibility
for the universe to be occupying some
space of a greater possibly infinite set
of
space that doesn't violate our known
laws of the universe
so inflation plays a big role in the
multiverse theory and including
its two major proponents andre linday
allen guth that worked the hardest on
inflationary cosmology
in the last 30 to 40 years they
basically say
you cannot escape the multiverse if you
have inflation
and because the universe appears to be
consistent with inflation so the story
goes
there must have been something like
inflation that took place therefore
there must be something like
a multiverse it's unavoidable what does
inflation do well it solves several
cosmological problems
that were once thought to be impossible
to not solve
and still call yourself possessing of a
proper theory of cosmogenesis or the
origin of the universe
it makes many many testable predictions
and
it also can predict that there are
regions of the universe
that could be much larger much vaster
than we could ever
hope to see with a telescope that we
have
operating today there's also
possibilities intriguingly
that come from the science of black
holes we've done lots of videos on black
holes including
uh this one that i'll put with dr
delilah gates
black hole basics and also her phd
thesis lecture
we'll have that up as well so what's
inside a black hole well nobody really
knows
nobody's been there could there be
wormholes that connect einstein rosen
bridges as they were once known
where you could teleport effectively
from one branch of the universe to
another one
uh seemingly faster than the speed of
light because you basically excise the
distance between two
nominally very far separated points
so we don't know what's in there this is
a diagram that my
late great colleague dr andrew friedman
made in connection with lee smolin
has popularized some of these ideas of
cosmic darwinism that the more black
holes that are produced in the universe
universe is kind of their facility
depends on the number of black holes and
type of black holes they produce
so andy made these wonderful diagrams of
what could happen inside of a black hole
um and uh just again this this is a
tribute to him
as much as to any of the other types of
scientists that we'll be talking about
today
now eternal inflation is a concept
popularized in in large part by andre
linde up at stanford university
who has said things to the extent that
we shouldn't be biased towards a
prejudice that there's only one universe
in other words in his conception there
could be multiple universes
more naturally than single universes and
in such
universes in the multiverse it's hard he
claims for inflation to happen only once
in other words there's inflation going
on all the time in all locations in the
super space of events
in what's called eternal inflation
there's also something called the string
theory landscape which predicts that
string theory of string theory is
true there are actually multiple
dimensions beyond the three spatial
dimensions in one time dimension
and actually those space-time dimensions
can effectively be thought about as
inaccessible dimensions that we don't
have access to and
actually the number of so-called vacuo
of compact manifolds and their
properties
are so numerous that actually each one
could be
identified isomorphic to another
universe a universe with different
physical constants different physical
laws
in what's called the string theory
landscape that leads to many possible
universes
and in eternal inflation you basically
seed or
spread out the possibility for eternal
inflation to populate the string
landscape
now level two multiverse is where you
have different post-inflationary bubbles
so in other words the laws of physics
the laws of mathematics could be the
same can be considered the same
but the laws of nature the the constants
that we observe gravitational constant
speed of light etc
would be different in such universes now
is there any evidence for them well
if we didn't have a cmb and we didn't
have some properties consistent with
inflation
we could rule this type of behavior out
so the fact that we
have these two observations consistency
with some aspects of inflation
although some likes paul steinhardt and
others have objected to that as a
criteria for scientific
progress nevertheless we could also hope
to explain
why our universe is so finely tuned at
least
our part of the universe is just the
lucky goldilocks universe
that happened to inhabit a region of
this vast string landscape
populated by eternal inflationary cosmic
bubbles
and that was bound to have just the
right constants of nature
as i explained in a video called the
faith of a physicist
look for that video as well so now do we
have evidence for fine tuning well we
are sort of here and so that gives
powerful evidence that
life evolved at least in one corner of
the universe so the conditions must be
comprehensively commensurate with the
existence of intelligent beings who can
ask questions about the origin of life
and in fact ask why they're here and
that's kind of associated with the weak
anthropic
principle with many universes you can
turn the dial infinite number of times
perhaps
so one of them is bound to be right and
then we find ourselves in the universe
where these constants are finally tuned
for life we've had conversations about
that with stephen c meyer
who rejects that hypothesis and looks
for another underlying interpretation
now we see this in the universe at least
well in our local corner of the universe
or our galaxy our solar system is is
populated by objects in the so-called
habitable zone
around a temperature uh a star
temperature about 5500 kelvin
produces a habitable zone where water
can be liquefied and we do believe that
liquid water is some kind of a
prerequisite maybe some other solvent
liquid phosphine i don't know
could be considered a prerequisite for
life so at least the physical constants
of
uh our universe are compatible with life
and conscious life at that
but if you had many universes they could
all have different constants
and that would be like saying you know
well do we need to we find ourselves at
the exact distance we do
and not because there was some tuner but
because the laws of gravity and there's
so many different objects that could
have formed
planets eventually the logic goes that
one was bound to
be at just the right distance to support
liquid water and in fact the
earth is the dominant source of liquid
water in our solar system but there's
many other
forms of water in our solar system alone
let alone in other solar systems
so there is a problem that came to pass
which is called the cosmological
constant problem
that we seem to witness that the
universe is accelerating it's getting
farther and farther apart at a faster
and faster rate
galaxies are moving farther and farther
away from each other we've known that
for 100 years almost
but those galaxies and the rate at which
they're moving is also increasing with
time
for this uh the physicists pictured here
schmidt reese and
perlmutter were awarded the 2011 nobel
prize now if you compare what you
observe with these gentlemen and others
have observed since
it differs from the predicted value by
120 orders of magnitude
and this is quite embarrassing although
some people like steven weinberg have
made claims that if lambda were too big
the universe would expand too fast to
form galaxies in other words it'd be
rapidly expanding apart and
effectively it would expand forever and
we'd never get the nucleating force
that's required to produce galaxies
galaxies are required to host stars
stars host people
people are what we are so if the
multiverse exists there is a hope for
this anthropic explanation
that some of these universes do exist
where lambda is too big never forms
some are too small we don't know if that
would cause a problem to create
life then there's what's called the
level 3 multiverse we talked about this
with sean carroll
where effectively at any moment a
quantum measurement or quantum process
could take place
the universe splits into parallel
branches and in different branches of
the so-called universal wave function
the universe behaves differently this
universal wave function
this is obviously quite controversial
this is an interpretation of quantum
mechanics that explains the measurement
problem
and actually has some input onto the
so-called quantum computers i wouldn't
count this as evidence per se
direct evidence that the many worlds
interpretation is is true
but if we didn't have the double slit of
course we wouldn't be here to ask such
questions because we seem to believe
that the fundamental theory of quantum
mechanics has this uh particle wave
duality
and has this measurement incompatibility
problem uh this will be the subject of
another video some other time
but we don't know for sure that there's
any evidence per se that it's definitely
true
the last level of the multiverse is
called level four multiverse
and this exists sort of in the mind of
mathematicians this is really
popularized by max tag mark and others
and this is that every mathematical
object could exist
but that also means that other universes
would have different laws of not only
physics but of mathematics
mathematical structures we'd have we
have groups and sets and fields and
rings
there could be some other object we
can't even conceive of we don't know why
math works as wigner said so effectively
for mathematics in physics
again this is just a question right now
of philosophy multiverse isn't so much a
theory as it is a paradigm it has some
explanatory power to explain things like
the anthropic principle
but it is at best a consequence of
inflation
which itself at least in in the context
that i study at the level one and two
multiverse
but it is not yet at the level of a
theory
so we don't actually have to test all
possible predictions but we have to find
some
and the question is can inflation be
falsified and that's a big problem
for many people according to uh folks
like anna aegis
neil turock and paul steinhardt of
course there could have been things that
you could
have falsified about inflation already
namely the flatness of the universe is
not falsified and you can't really
if it were not if it were to be
falsified and there was a slight
positive or negative curvature
that would have falsified that so we
can't right now
see the entirety of this megaverse this
ultimate universe
we can talk about the different levels
of physical theories that we know about
we can attempt the probe quantum theory
better to understand
the the many worlds interpretation
multiverse scenario
and understand how that could or could
not be tested according to sean carroll
it can be tested experimentally
although to my mind to my knowledge has
not yet passed a test
that could be falsified therefore
motivating it so right now it is a
matter of almost philosophy of science
in terms of does the many worlds
explain more powerfully than say the
copenhagen interpretation
the last multiverse level level four is
is the universe mathematical it's a
multiverse mathematical
that is a very very tantalizing
and interesting concept to think about
so i'll leave you with these references
we're going to go into each one of these
topics in more and more detail
for now i want to recommend to check out
some of the videos i mentioned
and also check out some of these books
that are mentioned up here
if you enjoyed this video you definitely
want to check out this playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena
click here and hear my conversation with
juan maldacena of the institute for
advanced study
enjoy and don't forget to subscribe for
more amazing content